bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
paphos omer beaucoup de sujets on va
parler des banlieues de la situation
dans les banlieues avec notre invité
georges et mad qui est le créateur de la
compagnie co fondateur au fond des eaux
paisibles blackburn 3-3 vais donc vous
avez une expertise évidemment sur ce qui
se passe dans les banlieues on reviendra
sur les suites des des attentats du mois
de janvier on parlera aussi de politique
de françois hollande qui revient tout
émoustillé de kiev
on parlera aussi de ce qui s'est passé
peut-être dans le doubs de la montée du
front national parce que c'était un
échec c'était une réussite pour le front
national des élections départementales
où il ya beaucoup de candidats on
parlera aussi peut-être du procès
strauss kahn pourquoi pas et puis de ce
film dont tout le monde dit qu'il est
nul mais que tout le monde va voir qui
s'appelle 50 nuance degré surtout
véronique il termine c'est vous c'est
vous qui vous dit absolument parler de
ça parce que c'est votre sexualité au
fond donc non ça va mais on avait dit
qu'on ne donnait rien madrid qu'on avait
dit très
confiant bonjour en tandem ou là ça va
bien même jean charles lajoie denis je
vous dis avec un nouveau libre au zénith
et puisque vous êtes éditeur de
chefs-d'oeuvre de géraldine du bois
voilà mon premier roman polar non non
non non c'est un roman euphorisant c'est
l'histoire d'une petite vieille qui mise
dehors de son appartement et ce par la
très belle très belle histoire très très
bien et finalement j'en le débat dont on
va avoir parlé puis jean-luc madec jeu
ça va bien alors je ne sais pas d'où je
voulais commencer par vous parce que
évidemment je pense que vous avez été
touché par ce qui s'est passé au mois de
janvier et est ce que pour vous c'était
une surprise absolue est ce que vous
avez senti monter comme sa détention
parce que après tout vous avez beaucoup
travaillé drogue dans ce qu'on appelle
les quartiers et vous avez grâce à la
culture réussi à faire émerger des
choses mais peut-être que cette culture
est peut-être un port pas d'aujourd'hui
alors
à la question est-ce une surprise non
pas du tout absolument pas du tout
ensuite
le terme culture me paraît impropre car
en vérité la culture c'est déjà la somme
de ce qu'on a produit quand on quand on
est dans un processus pour se cultiver
donc je voudrais juste souligner le fait
que c'est le rapport à l'art
qui est émancipateur et que c'est un
petit peu là le principe actif de toutes
les démarches qu'on a mené notamment au
sein du projet black blanc beur d'accord
mais mais mais vous avez été en contact
avec voilà avec des windsor en
permanence
maintenant qu'ils pourraient être
sensibles à certains disent non
messieurs messieurs
il ya trente ans
il ya des tas jeunes gens qui avaient la
même énergie la même envie de vivre de
grandes aventures lointaine la même
envie d'être des héros pour eux mêmes
pour leur environnement et le processus
qu'on a mis en place avec le théâtre de
l'unité et quelques autres artistes ont
permis à tous ces jeunes gens de faire
histoire avec nous d'abord avec les
artistes de se faire reconnaître et
ensuite de pouvoir rentrer trouvé place
dans le récit commun il faut dire qu'il
ya urgence puisque nous étions au début
de la création d'une ville s'est dit
qu'on allait bien voilà qui était la
ville nouvelle à l'époque de saint
quentin en yvelines et que à cette
époque là nous étions appuyés sur tous
les savoir faire de l'éducation
populaire et avec des moyens conséquents
de l'état en particulier et disons des
pouvoirs publics en général volonté donc
politique absolument puis des moyens et
les mois ils seront enfin donc j'ai créé
une opération qui s'appelait infos
jeunes en quelques semaines on est sorti
du carrefour carrière on a mis en place
des ateliers qui durait une année où les
jeunes gens de 50 ans dit line était
confronté pendant une année
régulièrement à des professionnels en
tout genre il est capable de fabriquer
avec eux un objet une représentation
quelque chose qui était quand même
autrement plus efficace pour s'altérer
pour échanger que la simple vie d'une
équipe de télévision pendant une semaine
dans un collège et qui repart en se
disant je fais référence à une réunion
où j'étais au ministère de la culture
vendredi dernier puisque ces grands
raoult après après ces attentats et zinc
je comprends bien pour que tout le monde
puisse ou vendu sa connerie à dire la
culture vous faites quoi un mois jean
revenir tout de suite à l'essentiel la
culture elle fait quoi elle fait ce
qu'elle fait depuis 20 ans c'est à dire
elf elle consolide des grandes
institutions publiques qui se produisent
une offre de très très haute qualité
qui s'adresse à des gens raffiné et à
des gens motivés oui et là où passe à
gaza censée le faire à peu près selon
oui mais c'est là où passe 90% des
moyens des baux et des bulles j'osais je
dirais
99,99 alors avec les 0 01 % qui restent
ces dernières années après avoir coupé
l'ensemble du mouvement d'éducation
populaire notamment sur lequel s'appuie
l'ensemble des démarches des animateurs
socioculturels voyelles et l'herbe n'est
pas une fabrication dû au hasard mais
qui est vraiment un fait l'histoire il
la culture a repris le grand art les
beaux-arts comment disait aux 19e et
puis on a fabriqué une sorte de machin
qui s'appelle la politique de la ville
où finalement ce sont les institutions
publiques elles-mêmes qui se sont
instituées aux opérateurs cats ont perdu
en chemin on a perdu la capacité de
mettre au travail eux mêmes sur leur
propre récit et sur leur propre aventure
les habitants eux-mêmes même un tout
c'est simple vous avez senti une baisse
par exemple est de l'intérêt des
pouvoirs publiques et une baisse moins
sévère je suis sentie à la fois des
lâchetés et parfois même des sincérité
je dirais mal placé c'est quoi les
acheter alors les lâchetés sais c'est
plus facile de fabriquer un beau
monument briand qui attractif il produit
de la mondanité de l'arrière-plan
symbolique électorale que de mettre de
l'argent qui dont les effets ne sont pas
immédiatement visible parce que la
temporalité des processus dont je parle
n'est pas la même c'est pas un truc qui
se fait en un clin d'oeil c'est comme
faire pousser une plante à un moment où
il faut mettre x temps les deux tiers du
temps pour travailler la terre si on
voit rien et puis un moment ça va plus
c'est un petit truc certains y voient
l'arbre mais d'autres se
montant de vie est trop court
amusons-nous donc c'est de la gestion du
taux s'il faut la temporalité est
essentiel dans ce genre de
considérations là on a l'impression que
les gens parlent et les décideurs
politiques veulent congrès pour
immédiatement raconte que les choses se
voit vite quand le temps électoral c'est
pas un temps qui est dans la dans la
durée c'est un temps qui est sur trois
salles tombé depuis six ans le feu nuit
mais oui c'est vrai intriqués tout est
vrai qu'il est de plus en plus courts
tout à tour oui par les médias donc on
était dans des logis qui étaient les
suivantes gauche ou droite
les premières années on rassure
l'entreprise autant qu'on peut mais
souvent dans un rapport plutôt
clientéliste il n'y a pas vraiment de
projet et on calme les banlieues on
redistribue j'allais dire à quelques
clients électoraux parce qu on est
coincés dans cette logique et puis les
quelques années les deux ans qui précède
les élections ont fait du saupoudrage
c'est à dire on va essayer de rattraper
comme ça quelques électeurs avec
quelques préjugés notamment que les
milieux populaires sont des milieux qui
votent moins voir que les milieux
populaires dans lesquels se trouvent des
gens d'origine étrangère
ne sont pas des votes qui nous intéresse
que on continue de nier la francité d'un
certain nombre d'individus qui sont là
par le fait de l'histoire et qu'ils
n'ont pas envie d'avoir une histoire
différente que celle de l'autre autres
petits camarades de jeu ne renonçait
mais
nenê en france depuis très longtemps fin
dont la famille est originaire de france
depuis très longtemps donc voilà ça
c'est la catégorie l'acheter parce que
d'un côté cet investissement permet une
grande visibilité politique permet de se
faire réélire et alors qu'alain verse
il le temps pour que se réalise un
processus est trop court pour en tirer
un bénéfice électoral donc là on a déjà
un problème qui après une confrontation
de paradigme à chaque fois d'ailleurs
c'est le cas donc les deux ne s'accorde
pas et puis la deuxième par lâcheté et
par facilité donc je viens de m'en
expliquer à l'instant et parfois par
incompréhension c'est à dire que voilà
des gens qui sont encore convaincus j'ai
entendu une haute fonctionnaire du
ministère de la culture très récemment
dire qu' il n'y a que les grandes
oeuvres qu'on peut transgresser
arriver jusque là
et puis bon je ne sais pas quelle idée
ce fait la transition week end mais
qu'est ce que j'aurais qu'est ce que ces
façades restaurées en a pour un moment
timo logique les uns les autres vous
êtes intéressé par phases c'est vrai
qu'il connaît bien perrin qui l'a bien
vu les sanctionner j'en suis expert que
du seul fait de mon expérience bien sûr
non mais je souhaite poser cette
définition jersey car je j'ai beaucoup
subi de toutes les autres sortes quand
je marche de l'expertisé mais c'est vrai
que les autres je les ai mises avait
mûri ce que voulait dire aussi c'est
qu'il ya donc un accès à la création
finalement qui n'existe plus et ça les
gens c'est de la co création on est
quand même des ragots réelles des gens
qu'on a en face de nous nous ne sommes
plus dans un rapport de domination la
connaissance n'est pas utilisée dans un
rapport de domination première évidence
qui est sorti des limites de ce coffret
l'école
aristote disait il faut amener les
enfants dans le parc
l'école doit se poser cette question un
projet comme la glandeurs d'autres du
même ordre qui se regroupent d'ailleurs
au sein de l'association art factory ce
dont je suis l'un des cofondateurs et
qui a posé cette problématique car
territoire population amène les enfants
dans le parc on s'amène avec on se met
un peu en danger on s'implique en tant
que personne pas simplement en tant que
représentant de l'état ou de je ne sais
quelle institution comme ça d'un symbole
un peu lointain et puis je vais pourrait
définir un peu tous les éléments
objectifs qui font un moment donné alors
oui ce ce qu'on appelait le défi dans la
danse hip hop au début je trouve que
vous avez dit nationalement c'est la
belle image de cette manière de
sociométrie car c'est quoi le défi alors
le défi c'est ce qui est devenu le
battle entre temps cherchez l'erreur
c'est une confrontation
cette confrontation elle ne se fait pas
dans un rapport de compétition oui des
questions d'écraser l'autre elle se fait
dans un rapport deux confrontations
d'abord à soi-même à sa propre
progression et ensuite elle est renvoyée
à l'appréciation de l'autre vous êtes à
la circonférence au même plan que les
autres vous avez terminé d'être le
centre vous revenez à la circonférence
ça a beaucoup d'avenir voyez moi c'est
pas un peu curieux de créer comme ça des
cultures pour partie de la population
c'est à dire que j'ai rien contre le hip
hop mais le but de hip hop je dire ça
parle à qui ça parle aux gens qu
effectivement d'un certain milieu dans
une certaines banlieues et s'affranchir
à jamais le cap de ce que dénoncer tout
à l'heure les beaux quartiers les gens
cultivés donc je veux dire pourquoi
pourquoi avoir une culture on a un peu
l'impression qu'il ya une sous culture
en débat tient ça pour la banlieue ça
c'est pas mal on va les faire danser on
allait faire on va faire des défis à
faire des choses c'est un peu curieux
parce que parliez tout à l'heure de
grandes oeuvres c'est important les
grandes oeuvres et de la culture soit je
dire c'est parce qu'on est en banlieue
qu'on pouvait pas s'intéresser à proust
6 face aux giants bulle fr finalement
absolument sauf que quand on est en
banlieue on n'a pas le référentiel
lumière ce que c'est on n'a pas le désir
si rien n'a été construit pour que vous
ayez vous même la capacité d'aller vous
poser la question de ce que peut vous
apporter proust ou de ce que vous a
apporté les propositions qui sont faites
dans les hauts lieux donc je voudrais
rectifier plusieurs choses dans ce que
vous dites d'abord je ne fais pas la
l'apologie du hip hop je cite un un
élément spatiale dans une des formes de
de l'expression du hip hop qui est une
des formes dans la danse qui était le
défi qui me paraît très intéressant à
étudier du point de vue de la sociaux
mais tri et la géométrie sociale on
pourrait développer si ça vous intéresse
donc rien de plus d'autre part quand
vous dites on je sais pas d'où vous
placez moi je préfère dire nous au je de
ce point de vue là et donc si le on sait
ce qu'ils considèrent ce que les autres
doivent avoir pour évoluer ou pour se
nourrir alors je dirais deux choses la
première bien sûr je le répète nous ne
sommes pas contre les offres les plus
raffinés puisque c'est l'objectif
l'objectif c'est de venir raffiné tout
le monde tout le monde
par contre là où on fait différence
c'est qu'on introduise que ce soit à
travers l'europe le hip hop c'est facile
c'est quelque chose qui leur parle
d'emblée donc c'est un point de départ
sur lequel on a une sorte d'accord
tacite après il faut pas faire d'erreur
et celui pop dance vous parle celui
qu'on a fabriqué un blabla c'est pas de
reproduire manière démagogique ce qui se
passe punta naiman dans la rue pour pour
l'intérêt ce qui était intéressant pour
nous c'était de poser la question de
l'écriture s'était posé la question de
l'arrière-plan de la construire une
pensée construire un esprit critique
voilà c'est que ce qui se joue alors ça
se joue dans cette expression artistique
comme dans d'autres hélas j'élargis en
disant que l'art pour moi ou les arts et
la recherche scientifique sont les deux
lieux de la capacité de transformation
des individus et des sociétés
c'était un des points essentiels de ce
que fut l'éducation populaire donc voilà
un premier élément de réponse ne pourra
pas me retrouver enfermé là dedans bien
entendu les grandes oeuvres alors là je
vais vous répondre très concrètement il
a fallu six ans parce que la magie
différence de 30 ans vécu au début on
disait même et vos évaluations
évidemment y est pas et à l'arrière
d'opposants arrêtés là alors ne pouvait
pas se référer mais en trente ans on a
construit nos évaluations on a observé
l'évolution des gens j'ai observé qu'il
fallait à peu près de moyenne de 6 ans
dans pour des gens qui rentrent dans un
processus pour transformer je le dire de
manière caricaturale naturellement mais
je pense que c'est le but pour
transformer l'achat d'un billet pour le
psg en achetant un billet pour l'opéra
mais si ça existe ça se fait changement
de milieu social changement de quartier
changement de regard sur le monde je
veux dire des trucs ça regarde et on a
ramené tous les jeunes de trappes
d'origine africaine nord africaines
antillaises chez eux et comment
reconnu beau
saison autres lire chez eux ça veut dire
chez eux dans leur culture dans l'ordre
dans leur pays d'origine dans les pneus
dans les pays s'envoler maison
originellement est arrivé là bas bien
entendu il était était évidemment pas
adapté non plus première tournée en
afrique de black blanc beur nos danseurs
ils arrivent en américains n'arrivent
pas au bout c'est à la fin de la tournée
qu'ils repartent en boubou c'est là où
les jolies je vais vous donner comme ça
quelques images précises pour vous voyez
où ça se joue un autre exemple tout bête
on prend le bus on est 50 dans un bus il
ya cinquante places il ya 50 des dons
blaster
tout le monde mais sa musique à fond
évidemment comme on veut l'entendre
mieux on la met un peu plus fort
reconnaissait ce processus alors d'abord
on discute et on dira c'est passé
musique que tout le monde va écouter
ensuite au bout d'un moment on en a
marre de cette musique parce qu'il ya
pas de raison que ce soit toujours le
même genre de musique
avec cette sorte de limite c'est une
richesse l'unité alors j'arrête tout je
dis voilà c'est mon quart d'heure
j'amène du maroc j'amène du classique je
me suis fait un sens oui mais au bout de
quelques années vous avez vu les pièces
que nous avons servi
du maroc sur du classique on intègre
l'abstraction et tout ce qui a fait de
la danse dite contemporaine la danse
contemporaine aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que à la différence près que nous avons
une geste qui est populaire que notre
boulot à nous c'était de faire de l'art
symbolisation d'un art populaire et ses
symboles remis en effectivité en
capacité de transformation et d'agir
sont là véritablement les fabrications
les plus intéressants de la conjoncture
d'un mouvement ou d'un autre d'un
spectacle ou d'un autre dirais même d'un
genre ou d'un autre j'espère abbas est
largement répandue que la plus grande
réussite de notre ami on a près de 30
ans d'expérience fabuleux c'est que
finalement black blanc beur est rentré
positivement dans le vocabulaire commun
c'est à dire que comme un satrape
d'autres choses tri gidere fermeture
éclair mais la raison butt est entré
dans le langage commun et quand on veut
exprimer aujourd'hui de façon positive
le mélange des individus quelle que soit
la nature de leurs activités on parle
d'un groupe black blanc beur c'est je
crois la plus belle résulte une que des
ses parts dans le détail
l'expérience et et toutes ces années
j'imagine que cette diète travail énorme
mais sa plus grande réussite là dessus
c'est d'ailleurs réussi à faire rentrer
black blanc beur de façon positive dans
le vocabulaire commun partage avons un
but ça ma vraie première est énorme et
seule trouvaille nommé véritable ans
j'en étais conscient alors j'en étais
conscient maman je les trouvais hier je
me suis rendu compte vous avez entendu
je vous parle de symbolisme pas mal
d'endroits dès le départ j'ai conçu ce
projet comme la constitution d'un
symbole qu'il fallait remplir qu'il
fallait valider dans lequel il fallait
mettre une valeur positive et les choses
quand un produit vont quand un symbole
eh ben on n'a pas besoin d'être exposé
d'éclater dans la tête des gens et dans
les médias il suffit qu'il existe pour
qu'il soit pour qu'il opère est ce que
vous venez de dire vas dans le centre du
pari que j'avais fait à cette époque et
j'ai été ravie au monde la coupe du
monde oui je vois la blague lambert
ressortir et je n'ai été d'autant plus
que ça faisait apparaître que
curieusement entre la création notre
compagne quelques temps forts qu'on
aurait pu être qualifié de la sorte et
cette coupe du monde et puis peut-être
l'après charlie qui s'est présenté sous
un autre angle mais qui repose la
question du vivre ensemble chier dans le
récit coma qui est en dehors et c'est
à chaque fois cette notion remonte comme
une valeur acquise de quelque chose de
positive dans la notion du vivre
ensemble et effectivement quand on aura
nos auront jaunies blanchis depuis
longtemps il est possible que ce soit ce
symbole qui continue à faire son travail
il avait déposé vous n'êtes pas joli
déposé je me suis fait piquer jeu les
robes paribas ce que moi je voulais pas
vendre des savonnettes allait vous
débutez pape aux joueurs il me fait
penser d'amendé
il parait il paraît mais
j'avais des plaisirs à quoi et à chaque
fois je veux bien devenir notre agent
j'ai eu des tas de
rapidement ce genre d'actifs
entendre
par contre est vraiment fasciné par
votre récit et furetage votre avis
l'éducation populaire n'est pas un
produit de consommation et aujourd'hui
je trouve que c'est considéré trop comme
ça dans le milieu par les pouvoirs
publics qui demande de remplir des
objectifs tout à fait
vain kid qui tique est en fait la notion
même d'éducation populaire qui est une
qui est une notion de co création comme
quand vous dites et la co-création ça
passe par une appropriation de 2d des
connaissances de 2 d'un échange d'une
éducation commune et celle inverse de
l'école finalement les coaches qui
balancent à savoir dont on et récepteurs
là c'est la création collective la
précédente émission quand je disais que
on apprend la vie à l'extérieur de
l'école je faisais bien sûr un référence
à l'éducation populaire
bien sûr
les gréements et comment parler je vous
ai pas d des réunions cas audio qui ont
lieu au but servent la culture ils se
rendent bien compte aussi tiens un mot
qu'à un moment donné qui est une absence
peut-être que c'est politique de la
ville ou en effet on tournait curité ou
dans lesquels ben c'est quand même
beaucoup d'argent mais on tournait un
port dans le monde rend compte par des
faussaires qu'on se rend compte quand
des choses commencent à nous péter non
c'est ça mais sans plus en plus en plus
ils sont gras savoye le trauma faire et
quelle capacité de recul et diagnostics
sur ce qui lui arrive mais ce que je dis
donc il faut aussi se méfier de ce que
je de ce qui sort dans le b cours de ce
genre de situation à commencer par les
médias justement non moi je râle je me
précipite pas pour dire des choses que
j'ai pas le temps de réfléchir et ça
c'est quand même un truc qu'il faut
qu'elle veut faust est tout à fait
d'accord à ce que vous dites ne pas
opposer l'école non
là l'art pédagogique c'est de la merde
ça n'existe pas l'art n'est pas
pédagogique par définition et c'est là
kilos qu'il opère par contre la
pédagogie c'est quelque chose qui peut
être fort utile ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui raccordés comme un moment
donné dans l'histoire d'éducation
populaire c'est
la place de l'école et le lien que
l'école peuvent faire je parlais de
l'aller dans le parc avec ce monde
extérieur le vrai monde le monde vrai
est ce que vous voulez qu'on passait à
la politique
avant que jessica vague et
dans le reste de l'émission mais c'est
vrai qu'il va y avoir les élections
départementales au départ tout le monde
se disait tout le monde s'en fout quoi
parce que c'est c'est parce qu'on
connaît très bien ce que sont ces des
élections départementales qui s'y
présentent et on se rend compte serait
ce que dans le territoire des yvelines
que au fond tous les maires importants
sont candidats à ces élections donc donc
ce sont des élections qui vont compter
on va regarder un petit sujet sur ces
candidatures
sont le canton de montigny le bretonneux
fin du suspense assez bien le maire de
montigny michèle losier présidente de
l'agglomération qui portera les couleurs
de la droite rassemblés sous la bannière
épi ensemble pour les yvelines dans
cette élection me paraît important que
le maire de montigny et président de
l'aco et aigle opération que je suis
soit présent dans ce combat puisque dans
les années à venir
le travail qui devrait être fait entre
la commune de l'intercommunalité et le
conseil général sera de plus en plus
important les valeurs sont toujours les
mêmes moi c'est essayer de d'avoir les
meilleurs résultats dans ma
collaboration avec le conseil général
aujourd'hui conseil départemental demain
sur les compétences qui sont les siennes
notamment pour tout ce qui touche à
l'action sociale pour tout ce qui touche
au collège aux routes de départementale
1 quand on observé à la loupe il est
actuellement détenu par le maire de
guyancourt françois de ligne et pour ces
élections le socialiste a constitué un
binôme avec sans une grande bande la
première fédérale des yvelines et lui
attrape mais qui a été pendant plusieurs
années conseillère municipale
d'opposition à montigny la gauche
apparaît divisée pour ces élections
europe ecologie les verts et le front de
gauche ayant décidé de présenter une
candidature à partir de ce territoire
que je souhaite défendre des valeurs
mais qui ont une résonance aussi
nationale ça va être des valeurs
sociales lutter contre les politiques
aujourd'hui d'austérité défendre en fait
véritablement la démocratie locale qui
est attaqué de différentes manières de
façon institutionnelle avec la réforme
des collectivités territoriales défendre
véritablement une politique sociale
puisque aujourd'hui ce seront
essentiellement les domaines sur
lesquels le département va intervenir et
ses politiques sociales elles sont sont
finalement mises en péril par une
politique d'austérité faire de la
politique un peu différemment donc on a
une équipe qui est très très jeune on a
une équipe de gens qui ne sont pas déjà
mère qui ne sont pas déjà vice président
de la communauté d'agglo donc vraiment
un renouveau de la politique pour bien
montrer que tous les citoyennes tous les
citoyens peuvent s'emparer de la
politique le front de gauche et europe
écologie les verts vont organiser des
ateliers de réflexion les 5 et 6 mars
afin de mobiliser le plus d'électeurs
autre binôme à se présenter cette fois
pour le front national et génie à la
vigne et sylvain grisons élus et de
montigny ancien militaire la sécurité et
son principal thème de campagne
la sécurité et je dirais
une certaine évolution de la physionomie
locale qui a énormément changé depuis 25
ans puisque j'habite
montigny-le-bretonneux depuis 1990 est
gelée considérablement vu changer et pas
uniquement montini bien évidemment nous
irons sur le terrain nous irons tracter
boîte est également
et tenir certainement des réunions
publiques lors des dernières élections
du canton 2008 françois de ligne et
l'avait emporté dès le premier tour avec
près de 52 % des voix son principal
adversaire déjà michel laugier et un
candidat divers gauche michel thomas
alors on voit que voilà dans les
yvelines par exemple il va y avoir un
combat entre entre michel laugier
françois de ligne et donc entraîner des
mers important président de la
communauté d'agglomération d'un côté
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ça
intéresse plus les partis politiques ces
élections que les électeurs à moi je
crois que oui dansons sous cette
élection cantonale va avec les élections
régionales au mois de juin être le moyen
à la fois pour les français de
s'exprimer et pour les élus de se
compter donc inévitablement les
retombées de cette élection cantonale
est également les retombées de
l'élection régionale marqueront très
fortement ce qui va se passer après pour
2017 c'était élection présidentielle qui
est la principale de sélection dans
notre république donc il y aura un
impact national évident et quand on voit
que les leaders s'implique dans les
cantonales ça veut bien dire ce que ça
veut dire qu'on tourne ou distingue
enfin ça fait ça fait longtemps
généralement que le parti au pouvoir
perd toutes les élections intermédiaires
je pense qu'on va surtout compter les
abstentionnistes mais enfin pris 70 ya
quand même beaucoup d'abstention tout le
monde s'en fout quasiment et surtout
personne ne sait pourquoi on va voter et
ce que vont faire les gens qui sont élus
c'est ça le vrai problème donc c'est une
d'élections dont les partis politiques
sont ravis et c'est normal c'est de
cette boule ou des partis politiques de
préparer une élection de présenter des
candidats de s'unir de se désunir sa c2
c'est le jeu démocratique et ça me ça me
ravit mais je pense qu'un énorme déficit
de d'informations sert personne ne sait
rien sur ces départements ça le reste je
suis quand même en campagne en ce moment
ils sont sur les marchés sont prêts à
discuter avec tout le monde et je trouve
que au contraire on peut leur poser des
questions très concrètes et y répondre
et il suffit d'aller leur demander aussi
ce qui fait qu'il est leur programme
vous c'est vraiment déçu mais aussi
élargir le département de le réformer
oui après cette chose et pas très bon
après ce qui est bien aussi cette année
si ce concept de binômes hommes femmes
et qui oblige à les chercher des femmes
ailleurs que dans le vivier de base des
militants les femmes de la vie civile
qui connaissent la vie et ça va être
très bien
vous êtes d'accord je trouve que
effectivement il ya des sites
d'information électorale que c'est pas
très clair ces élections notamment le
ministère de l'intérieur elle a changé
et les dénominations des listes d'union
de la gauche donc en fait par exemple
maintenant quand le ps sera encore
titulaire avec une autre formation de
gauche la donnée dénomination officielle
sera
l'union de la gauche et quand ce sera le
pcf veut élever ou le front de gauche
avec un autre parti ce sera divers
gauche en moi je pense que c'est passé
assez malvenu que le ps qui en a un qui
va perdre ces élections chercha à
dissimuler la réalité du jeu et des
clivages politiques à ce titre là il ya
un exemple assez formidable à la
verrière avec mallinger benoît hamon qui
ont énoncé une liste front de gauche ps
alors que c'est faux factuellement les
commissions du groupe pcf des trois
villes elancourt trappe la verrière ont
voté à 70 7 voix contre 5 contre une
liste d'union que le ps donc à linge âge
ne représente un pc f1 ne représente pas
front de gauche il représente lui-même
les derniers il y aura une liste
d'opposition
une deuxième liste de gauche face à sa
guise et bail à l'intérieur de la gauche
et des cycles le trac parce que 1 90%
contre et partir quand même sens à des
majors ça c'est un problème voyons ce
que les français vont dire hésitait 4
millions dans la rue le 11 janvier je
crois quand même que ces gens qui se
sont déplacés qui ont manifesté ont des
choses à dire et nous sommes dans un
pays démocratique
jean charles a raison je pense que la
problématique de ces cantonales et on la
retrouvera aux régionales c'est
l'abstention c'est là qu'on va voir si
le peuple de france intéresse ou pas à
son avenir et j'espère que l'abstention
ne sera pas aussi forte que nous
pourrions dire aujourd'hui voilà j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir dans la capacité des
français d'aller voter un message
aujourd'hui puisque
cette table de jeu nous permet je dis
aux français quelle que soit l'endroit
où ils habitent et leur couleur
politique aller voter ça faisait mal
voté oui bien sûr
vous n'êtes pas ne pas répondre j'aurai
plus de 1 un travers que je vous raymond
et que je livre à vous souhaitez pas de
souci
alors moi sur les contenus des
différents programmes mis à nu l'atuge
me prononcerai en tant que citoyen mais
aussi en tant que citoyen qui a
abandonné une certaine légitimité de son
action sur le territoire et de ce point
de vue là j'ai toujours soutenu en
le justifiant sur des choses très
concrètes les soutiens que j'apportais à
telle ou telle qu'ils sont pas
nécessairement des gens d'un parti ou
d'un autre la première et la deuxième
chose et j'ai pas envie d'ajouter
davantage de choses c'est que
effectivement c'est très intéressant
qu'il puisse y avoir des personnalités
qui soit cooptée en tout cas de
l'extérieur des partis parce que ça
m'amène à la réflexion je dois porter
autour de cette table c'est que là
encore le problème de la représentation
est biaisé par un objet qui le parti
c'est à dire une sorte d'objet verticale
qui ressemble à toutes les institutions
ou les rapports
du haut vers le bas de domination sont à
l'oeuvre et outre est furieusement
se produit les se construisent les
contenus qu'ensuite on va mettre en
musique dans la représentation élue il
ya comme une merde
s'appelle l'absence de représentativité
c'est sur notre pays est l'absence ou la
faiblesse des corps intermédiaires je
suis pas d'accord il faudrait qu'ils
fassent labour
party coalition des partis politiques on
critique beaucoup trop alors
effectivement des choses à revoir mais
les partis politiques c'est quand même
des des lieux et des ombres où les gens
réfléchissent je suive les gens que
gilles rammant et on n'est pas dans un
espèce de café du commerce permanent je
veux dire avec cette représentation que
tu critiques sans arrêt qui serait pas
démocratique c'est des gens qui se
présentent et des gens qui bossent on a
ou pas leurs idées politiques mais en
face c'était des gens qui réagissent à
peu de temps en temps et l'a donc que
les partis politiques sont
indispensables je pense que même s'il ya
la parité je crois quand même c'est
parti politique qui décide mercredi
même si vous allez chercher ailleurs
bien que l'heure était à la remise en
cause des sites et politique mais de la
manière de se construit cette
représentation et dont elles
transmettent dont elle est transmise
effectivement dans l'action publique
c'est j'ai pas de solution à déballer
com ça en trois phrases mais j'ai
quelques idées quand même sur la manière
avec laquelle on peut faire société
rurale et produire à partir d'un nouveau
paradigme de nouvelles représentations
notamment où on voit très bien quand
vous le disais en entrée de sujets que
les maires se présente pour des
élections départementales pourquoi cette
élection qui sont pas franchement super
importante pourquoi ne pas faire
confiance à d'autres personnes qui ne
sont pas encore
c'est pour ça que je ne verserai
renoncer à la politique qui fait qu'à
certains d'eux
le déluge je pense notamment aux élus de
l'opposition se disent que c'est le bon
moment pour se présenter
pour prendre des sièges
oui mais en même temps vous savez oui
c'est que vous avez raison probablement
sur le fond mais en même temps c'est
vrai que les gens sont assez attachés à
des dons qu'ils connaissent
peut-être vous non même si
des personnages hantés vote pour des
gens je suis pas toujours bon départ que
la bd est ce que la partie visuelle
rescousse autres ikea parti musulman et
puisqu'il ya particulier le manque et
qui présentent des conditions des
candidats est ce que ce trick et des
représentants du parti musulman parti
musulman dans ces élections par exemple
ici lors ce territoire moi je vais vous
répondre tout de suite enfin j'estime
que j'ai pas souhaité ou pas qui on est
je peux simplement vous dire ce que j'en
pense oui oui moi je pense que la
religion comme la nature des genres des
uns et des autres la nature des ethnies
des origines ou comme la nature de
comment dirais-je les différentes
classes d'âge des différents habitants
n'a rien à voir mais ne représente vous
permet de aucune forme de représentation
efficace je pense que je pense
véritablement que c'est sur un programme
sur une personne ou sur un groupe qu'il
faut se préserver mais pour moi une
religion pour autant qu'elle soit
décryptable comme un programme ça me
paraît assez spéciaux et on voit ce que
ça donne quand les états deviendrait le
religieux quand la religion prend le pas
à en donner sur une expression plus
large et plus ouverte donc moins bien
appartenir démocrate
la représentation qui me paraîtrait la
plus la plus appropriée selon les
certains pays font jurés leur président
sur la bible vrai notamment 1 je
considère pour ma part très modestement
que la religion est une affaire
strictement personnelle et intime et que
la religion n'a pas à se mêler de
politique voilà c'est ce qui à paraître
dans ma réflexion intellectuelle
maintenant pouvoir venir ce que disait
jean charles moi je n'attaque pas les
parties je ne considère pas comme les
parties
des choses sans intérêts non en allant
des partis politiques bien entendu
doivent représenter le peuple ce qui
m'inquiète moi et je reviens sur ce que
vous dit à l'instant c'est que il ya une
difficulté entre le parti politique à la
représentation du peuple français et je
considère il ya peut-être pas assez de
monde dans les paris à la maison mais
les gens changent à chaque fois me dit
mais non dans les salles à je considère
que les syndicats salariés c'est qui
s'est essentiellement des syndicats de
fonctionnaires les syndicats patronaux
on n'entend parler que du medef moi je
suis désolé je représente des quantités
des dizaines de milliers d'entreprises
qui ne sont pas représentés par le medef
est hélas mon ami sparadrap sur toutes
les autres représentations patronales ou
salariés dans ce pays et je considère qu
on n'encourage pas suffisamment de
syndical au syndicat ce qu'elles soient
salariés ou patronal donc je crois qu'il
ya un effort considérable à faire dans
ce domaine en france et peut-être qu'il
faudrait que les citoyens se mettre dans
les parties après tout
de pouvoir les coalitions n'envie
personne on est ce que la rue y assure
qu'il n'aurait pas envie mais là la
structure même de l'organisation de
notre pays est telle qu on n'est pas
très motivée et peu mobilisé sauf
sociale et cadres du rpt comme au mois
de janvier où là vous avez vu la
réaction du peuple a été très très fort
mais je pose la question pourquoi est ce
qu'on devrait se mettre dans des parties
quand on voit deux des militants n'est
pas respectée moi je prends l'exemple
je veux dire aussi de fonctionnement des
partis politiques qui fait que quand les
personnes restent neutres vous pouvoir
et s'émancipe de leurs bases ça c'est un
fait sociologique qui avaient été
démontrés
s'émancipe de leurs bases elles vont
chercher là où est leur intérêt
personnel et je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'il faut tourner justement on en
revient à 7 ce système de tourner et de
laisser sa place au plus haut plus jeune
des candidats avant des élections dans
le dans le doubs bardon
noms comme ceux qui passent en vous
entendant j'ai remarqué autre chose
aussi qui n'est pas que l'apanage des
élus mais chez eux c'est évidemment
dommage c'est que autrefois le bourgeois
gentilhomme voulait devenir raffinée et
cultivée aujourd'hui il a juste besoin
de s'enrichir et ça c'est vrai aussi
dans dans la représentation c'est à dire
que
je suis frappé j'ai participé à de
nombreuses campagnes inde et au niveau
des tas niveau j'ai approché les gens
mais vraiment à tous les niveaux
je constate depuis au moins quinzaine
d'années que nous sommes alors c'est
pareil pathos et ne pense pas ces gens
qui pensent pas quand arrive avec une
idée une vraie idée à mettre au travail
pour penser de dire mais c'est déjà trop
tard maintenant il faut des éléments de
langage et donc je sois meilleur que
l'on
à quel moment y pense
messieurs non mais moi c'est un truc
simple qui me fera représenter
c'est bien le problème dans ce pays
voilà les corps intermédiaires n'existe
pas tant qu'on en sera là on n'avancera
pas un mot sur les élections du doubs
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une vie
qui alors il ya eu deux analyses des
offices et la victoire du front national
puisque après tout c'est pas loin de 50
% et puis d'autres analyses qui est de
dire mais après tout le front national
n'arrive quand même pas être élu même
dans des circonstances qui pourraient
lui est plutôt favorable parce qu'entre
ces deux analyses il a quelle est la
vôtre je constate que l'élection de
chirac
c'était 83 ans
c'était 80 20 et que là c'est 51 49 donc
c'est assez inquiétant 700 voix
différence et c'est très très peu
après jeu chacun peut en tirer des
conclusions on peut dire que la droite
une certaine perméabilité entre la
droite et l'extrême droite c'est
probablement vrai mais pas plus
inquiétant que ça parce que c'est
surtout surtout aussi peut-être pas si
mal 5 ça de ne pas mélanger le ps et de
l udf parce que ça s'éteint à terme ça
marche effectivement chirac le pen mais
mais à terme on mélange tout et puis on
n'avance pas donc le ps c'est pas l'udf
c'est pas le ps donc je moi je peux
comprendre mais pas fait à titre
personnel mais je comprends très bien
qu'un type de l'udf ne vote pas pour le
bolide a duré de l'ump ne veut pas pour
le ps comme je comprendrais très bien
qu'un mec du ps ne soutiennent pas un
mec de l'udf dans l'autre cas parce que
c'est tout mélanger et sait mettre une
couverture sur la sur la poussière enfin
la poussière sous le tapis puis voilà
quoi dit on verra bien dans dix ans mais
on voit que c'est comme ça que front
national mais est ce qu'on n'a pas fait
déjà un avant-goût de ce que sera
l'élection présidentielle
en plus on est dans une circonscription
ancré à gauche historiquement oui à papa
totalement il s'est vraiment passé en
termes de il quand même et j'avoue qu'on
puisse cacher donc c'est c'est un signe
c'est un signe il peut nous inquiéter
mais ça veut dire que celui qui se
présente contre front national était à
chaque fois c'est bien j'espère quel
futur c'est bien qu'elle y était c'est
bien le calcul d'ailleurs delà de la
droite républicaine et du persil
styliste
chars et reporter enfin
mettez vous oui c'est la faute d'un
fantasme en 2017 et voyons ce que
donnerait une élection entre une
représentante du front national chez les
évacués et un homme de gauche porteur d
échec de cinq années de mandarin
ça fait peur mais je disais je lisais un
truc nous sommes là maintenant à peu
près dans le même scénario politique que
nos amis grecs avec 6 brasse mais oui
depuis un peu différente nous avons trop
d'éléments prospectifs simplement à la
question qui était posée évidemment
c'est pas une victoire du front national
le front national c'est toujours un
résultat par défaut alors moi ce qui
m'intéresse toujours c'est que défaut de
quoi les et là dessus que j'ai tendance
à réfléchir j'ai pas non plus la des
révélations à faire évidemment mais le
défaut de quoi le défaut de contenu le
défaut de sens enfin tout ce qui fait
qu'à un moment donné on va voir comment
alors ça c'est peut-être énorme ce que
je dire mais comment un mec comme hitler
arrive au pouvoir par défaut peur défaut
peur défaut pour le vol ou la maman la
plus gaga qui rassure tout le monde vers
le vote le garde qui transforme les
tombereaux deutschemark de la femme
n'est des années misère commandes après
le krach de wall street et effet sur
l'europe en rassurant ce alors c'est le
bon gars et quand les gens enfin quand
les gens ont peur quand des gens ont
froid ils prennent d'abord ce qui les
réchauffe pays réfléchissent après moi
je prône évidemment que pendant qu'on en
a les moyens pendant qu'on ait encore de
sociétés assez riche on se donne les
moyens de permettre à chacun de
réfléchir oui c'est ce que je dirai à
cette occasion mais est ce que justement
vous avez pas parce que ça me frappe un
petit peu c'est que tout le monde a fait
son deuil en se disant on dit 17 il y
aura un candidat contre le front
national b mais comme si c'était des
vidéos c'est comme si c'était comme si
pas d'autres possibilités
au delà de dix ans au fond c'est plutôt
bon signe parce que si on deuxième tour
on sera élu au delà de l'erreur et il ya
la carte laquelle
s'est pas entendu
le lpc d'être qualifiés ou pour les iem
tout à force désertion est qualifié à
force de dire que tout le monde dit que
le front national sera au deuxième tour
c'est qu'il sera vraiment au deuxième
tour donc il faut aussi commencer à
aller dans le fatalisme dans la dos
relais dans les quartiers dans les lieux
de vie voir ce qui se dit et faire de
l'éducation populaire
tout à fait entendre cette parole et
puis la remette à bonne distance c'est
un bar on est au coeur sculpteur
d'alleurs et devolder de l'incapacité à
fabriquer cette distance les gens qui
n'ont pas étudié l'histoire
évidemment non pas cette distance ils
vont aller vers une facilité vers dollar
assurances immédiat ce qui est une
grande somme toute assez humain dès
qu'on a quelques connaissances quelques
reculs on est capable de dire attention
là ça a l'air sympa comme ça ça me
rassure maintenant mais qu'y at il
derrière voilà mais souvent le jeu des
différents partis et des rapports de
force entre les parties
là aussi ce fait au dessus du sens que
pourrait éventuellement donner des
habitants un contenu politique ou un
espace politique il faut s'en méfier
rendre le fn fort pour affaiblir le pc
ça a été une stratégie littéralement
quelque part on en paye que je suis pas
particulièrement bon plus que ça servait
beaucoup oui mais on détruit des choses
ont détruit les choses qu'ils ne
repoussent pas qui remonte pas comme sa
surface donc attention parce qu'en 17
ça peut passer le cap ça peut passer le
pas oui un petit moment de colère en
plus un petit climat qui se dérègle il
fait chaud peut-être trois jours de trop
de plus oui mais il ya des violences il
avait travaillé les événements la jeune
femme qui avait été contrôlé avec le
voilà très bon c'était juste un peu les
marmites comme salon c'était début de
ramadhan pleine lune si vous mettez tous
des éléments réellement objectifs sur
les comportements humains vous rendez
compte que c'était sa part doivent aussi
ça se passe autrement
ah oui ça c'est comme il dit c'est que
ce jour là à imaginer une femme de
chambre dans un grand hôtel en train de
faire une gâterie intègre alors
justement allez on n'est pas bien est ce
que vous avez fait est ce que vous avez
un peu suivi le procès strauss kahn
parce qu'on appelle quand strauss kahn
georges eddy carlton a quant à elle eu
un petit peu et est ce que vous êtes son
peu d'intérêt mais mais mais c'est assez
intéressant parce que il ya d'un côté le
plan juridique d'ailleurs le président
l'a assez bien lui on est là pour faire
du droit on n'est pas là pour faire de
la morale
or on a la pression qui s'est quand même
un procès assez morale me
font c'est qu'ils s'y intéressent
attendent c'est d'avoir un peu un peu de
nettoyage parce que là visiblement on
est allé avec ce monsieur qui est
représentatif d'une certaine forme de
cette société de l'élite oui
intellectuelle matériellement très à
l'aise et qui souvent ne vient pas tous
les mois les quelques amis que j'ai que
avec lesquels on part de cette affaire
me disent tous c'est dégueulasse il faut
nettoyer tout ça est donc ce monsieur
est finalement la caricature la
représentation de ces dérives abominable
qui ne sont plus supportés par la
société française bon je sais pas ce
qu'il en sera mais en tout état de cause
je m'y intéresse qu de loin j'ai pas
très envie de connaître les détails des
habitudes sexuelles de strauss kahn ça
m'intéresse assez peu l'impression qu'il
y aura probablement une victoire
judiciaire et une défaite morale mais
espérons que
le
non il va être acquitté
les trois films qui sont arrivés qui se
font accusé d'exhibitionnisme sexuels
alors que c'était juste un acte
politique
somme toute assez courageux et en plus
évident et
c'est quoi
sa courageuse à kayes en place et c'est
pas le mec courageux de montrer ses
seins sur la place monge jouissive
le vrai le fond du problème c'est que
c'est effectivement sur la morale mais
le vrai est la vraie seule question
c'est est-ce que oui ou non
la prostituée qui dit qu'elle a été
violée par strauss kahn elle dit j'ai le
mec me tenaient les mains et je me suis
fait c'est quand même la
définition typique d'un viol ça veut
dire si vous voilà ce que les rien du
tout donc soit c'est un viol il faut
qu'il soit que c'est dur mais sinon
après il peut se de mise et qu'il veut
c'est son problème si la nana et
consentants ces maisons donc si on
déborde complètement soit soit il a
violé quelqu'un et c'est effectivement
extrêmement répréhensible et c'est pour
ça qu'il faut lui faire un procès mais
ce soir
je
l'aimais le code pénal qu'on doublera le
vent saynètes s'il ya deux critères bon
je
sais que ça mériterait des heures de
débat t'avoir mai mais en tout cas ce
qui est important si vraiment il est
avéré qu'il ya un type qui tient une
nana pendant que l'autre le monde dedans
je suis désolé c'est tout c'est un viol
donc vous ne devez pas connaître
royal dirais que c'est glauque itude
maintes affligeant ce qu'a fait jean
sait que c'est toujours eux c'est lui
qu'on écoute c'est la description des
fêtes de ça c'est bien pire que c'est
après qu'on nous avait vus quand même
que les sondages disent qu'il aurait
fait un meilleur président que françois
hollande après ça ça me retire rien à
ses compétences intellectuelles là on la
ceinture comment est ce qui aurait pu
imaginer que ces personnes ne soient pas
payés je sais pas je suis
tombé dans l'article mais pas les avoir
des tonnes d'histoires déjeuner au
palais de justice du même genre il sait
pas ce cas que strauss kahn n'est
derrière plein de mecs qui se conduisent
comme ça plein de nanas qui ont sept
vilains etc je veux dire c'est le
quotidien des tribunaux donc la triste
image 10 mars il faut nettoyer au coin
des guerriers que la société procède à
une personnalité qui doit pas être très
sympathique sexuellement pour la
majorité des filles qui rencontre c'est
une évidence puis voilà mais il est
représentatif de rien si ce n'est que
lui-même strauss kahn faut vous faut pas
en faire un tel qu'il est présenté par
la presse et une reprise est présenté
comme une caricature quand même
c'est un bon client
y
aller parce qu'il reste que sa voix
c'est la justice parce que c'est
excellent bien oui mais parce que c'est
extrêmement croustillons parce que
j'allais oublier que ça y est c'est aux
côtés de la perversion sexuelle et puis
de 2 de ceux qui commentent et qui
regarde du voyeurisme je
sais vraiment sur ça je m'en fous les
gens lui que c'est un peu ça rosiers
mention ça m'intéresse pas du tout j'ai
même pas envie d'en
faire c'est très bien que ça intéresse
tout ça amuse tout le monde c'est
croustillant mais bon je suis pas fan
c'est pourquoi est ce que tout le monde
va les voir rire et pour garder c'est
pour les mêmes raisons vous allez le
voir
5en régionale ailleurs le livre est
comme le film à part apparemment est
encore plus intel core et lui enfin il
fait quand même c'est pas faux parisien
par exemple deux courts et que certaines
gares
la jeune fille est tout le monde le tout
le monde c'est encore une grosse
cavalerie de marketing
des films tournés qui dont dont il en
arrive à dire tout le monde mais c'est
quoi ça c'est de la fabrication de
marketing on va tous les jours comme à
leur bureau autant d'excusés première
riendeau et amel rdr c'est très beau
mais oui à consentir sa méchante le
pitch deux minutes de cette affaire-là
elle relie ces histoires d'eau oui c'est
l'histoire de lurons 12 ans basquiat des
jeux d'écriture est ce que je dis là
c'est de la balle à terre mais après je
conçois même que des tas de gens qui
puissent s'éclater là dedans et des tas
de deux femmes quel que soit leur âge
qui a abandonné peuvent saisir aventure
pour fabriquer leur propre capacité à
s'évader parce que les chansons passé
lorsqu'on lit et ce qu'on vit quand on
lis ces mêmes heureusement que c'est
assez compliqué et des puissants mais
sorti de là retombe dans ce que je
disais tout à l'heure par rapport aux 6
à la sphère de strauss kahn s'il ya un
moment où il est question de faire de ce
bouquin une sorte de somme et après on
peut pas revenir en arrière et on va
dire que c'est nul mais tout le monde y
va alors on y va pour quoi pour pouvoir
en parler de l'accord entre l'école munk
en jette pas la télé là on est emmerdé
et personne n'a en revanche pas parler
des épisodes avec six autres mois non
mais chaque saison
à wil locales et on sait que ça comme
roland shirts et qu'ils sont même si ça
a quand même fait augmenter beaucoup le
la fabrication et la vente de sextoys
ton cahier une provision de ficelle
voilà presque incroyable c'est que ça
soit permis aux enfants de 12 ans
d'aller voir ce film et en france est
oui en france et moi sommes seuls 12 ans
c'est une image dégradante avilissantes
demain à nice était comme ça désolé j'ai
peu d'imagination sur le plot oui c'est
ça oui non c'est un constat de carence
et c'est tout le soft je te fais truc
regretté que ce soit moins cru que les
aventures de notre ami strauss kahn
parce que l'une et l'autre nous
intéresse en rien ni l'une
à oui oui ou non de transgresse
utilement que les grandes vrai nom mais
c'est vrai histoire d'eau était quelque
chose transgresse il faut te fais mais
de la même manière que toutes les formes
un peu populaire de type roman de gare
et ils ont les mêmes difficultés que
souvent les méformes populaire je parle
dans le spectacle vivant portion garder
dire qu'il faut que ce soit installée
dans la reconnaissance pendant 20 ans ou
30 ans pour que ça puisse être considéré
comme faisant partie du patrimoine à sa
juste place sinon en général c'est
regarder d'en haut par des gens qui
disent c'est d'une inculture de série b
c'est d'une autre chose us ou 2 matchs à
sousse oui évidemment tout dépend d'où
on regarde enfin en tout cas le film
c'est assez rare il ya quand même deux
cent mille personnes qui ont pré
réserver
nos billets dans joe's donc c'est énorme
et puis avant le film c'est quelque
chose qui a tiré
le marché du livre lescornez se
rapportent des gens ça ramène des gens
librairie c'est merveilleux
juste un mot avant qu'on compte le
midwest il vous savez cette enquête du
monde sur des comptes en suisse qui a
livré comme ça quelques noms en pâture
est ce qu'on sait que c'est alors pierre
bergé qui lui a donné des actionnaires
du monde a trouvé ça absolument horrible
rappelons que c'est ce qui se faisait
pour de l'occupation qui s'était de la
délation est ce que vous pensez que
c'est bien ou pas bien de donner des
noms comme ça où pâturent souvent en
plus des gens qui ont des chats qui sont
qui sont pas c'est pas du tout les
régulariser leur situation c'est ça qui
est un peu curieux c'est d'avoir balancé
les noms sans aucune graduation c'est à
dire que j'ai rien ni fourni comme gad
elmaleh mais bon
la somme un peu ric instruit ses quatre
joueurs
avec gabriel et principes aussi c'est
quand même curieux qu'avec autant de
pognon parce qu'il est riche ici vous a
décidé mercredi à damas demande est
intellectuellement c'est curieux mais
visiblement il avait apprécié avait
régularisé il ya plein de gens qui ont
regardé ce qui se retrouve sur cette
liste alors après effectivement c'est
très difficile d'avoir une opinion très
tranchées parce que si on dit si on est
de l'avis de pierre bergé ça veut dire
on est une petit carton score rapide on
se protège les uns les autres mais en
même temps si on sûr si on arrive à
faire abstraction de ces sommes ce petit
problème c'est vrai que c'est un peu
choquant comme de balancer des trucs la
présomption d'innocence est complètement
balayées on a balancé deux hommes parce
qu'après le type le gad elmaleh pour
ramasser pour pour rattraper la pente
sera mais je ne fais rêver pour les
radios caste toujours la même défiance
c'est assez terrifiant alors clairement
les noms qui ont été balancés pour le
grand public c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt tout le monde le sait je rappelle
le chiffre comme ses 180 milliards
d'euros de détournements les plus gros
les plus gros sont déjà partis ils sont
déjà identifiés sans cause depuis sept
ans dans cette affaire c'est bien car
tout est hélas des victimes parce que si
vous suivez un peu cette affaire il ya
des morts 1 d'accord dans d'autres
affaires aussi glauque et aussi
terrifiante d'ead moindre portée
financière clearstream par exemple c'est
des choses absolument abominable et ça
on devrait en parler avec un tout petit
peu plus sur
la wii est excellent justement parce
qu'il va falloir centriste jean débat
est justement par la question là où je
suis d'accord moi
comment ça belleu berger avec berger
c'est que c'est pas la peine de mettre
les gens place publique ne vois pas
l'intérêt par contre que ces gens là
soient dénoncés à la justice en bonne
observation de la loi ça me paraît une
évidence c'est autre chose incontestable
aussi c'est en un mot est ce qu'une
actualité de black blanc beur oui alors
on prépare comment dirais-je un film
avec une société de production qui
s'appelle château rouge sur une sorte de
synthèse un deuxième documentaire à
l'occasion des 30 ans toujours sur le
thème il a compris qu'il nous tient à
coeur c'est à dire que au delà même de
nos histoires des gestes bobo d'une
époque où d'une autre qu'on a pu
produire le fait qu'on ait été un des
constituants du récit local régional
national pour le coup et je le
revendique oui il ya d'abord ces
européens hervé d'abord européen oui
parce qu'en des biens les désavantages
bien sûr nos mémoires ou les antilles
est d'abord européen dire que s'il y
avait eu une dizaine d'expérimentations
de ce genre capable de mettre en
histoire comme erasmus à travers des
histoires de cette nature-là serre qui
consolide des liens avis qui fabrique
la société alors oui je pense qu'on
aurait fabriqué de l'europe et après on
en aurait fait les contours et on aurait
plus facilement réussi à nos harmoniser
la fiscalité à faire affaire est un truc
qu'on arrive pas jamais à faire parce
qu'on fait tout à l'envers alors le
documentaire est en train de se faire et
alors on en reparlera
alors jean ce galop d'essai depuis peu
pts et les chiens en et parthenay jeu
via un titre mais je ne donne pas encore
ça peut encore changer voire qu'il
pourrait bien y aura sans doute aussi
une soirée avec les anciens de la
compagnie où viendront quelques amis
stars et d'autres moins comme manu
dibango peut-être dont j'attends la
confirmation
dj abdel qui a déjà donné sa
confirmation et quelques autres très
connue avec lesquels
ça c'est leur problème pas de police des
frontières et au tulle pas à l'ordre et
merci pour tout cas merci beaucoup
merci à vous tous et on se retrouve très
vite pour un nouveau pacte